[BLANK_AUDIO]
Hi, guys.
Welcome to Webcast.
Today, we're going to be talking
about stage two tips and tricks.
And my name's Rahul,
I'm a Udacity coach.
>> I'm Anthony.
>> Also a Udacity coach.
And yeah, so
today we want to address some issues
that you guys might have been having
with the code your own quiz project.
And by the end of this webcast hopefully
you'll have an idea of not only how
to approach this particular programming
problem posed by stage two but
also programming problems in general,
is being able to identify a problem and
break it down.
>> Yeah definitely, so before this
webcast we looked into some of that
common reasons why students do not meet
specifications on the stage two project.
And the top reasons we're not commenting
at the beginning of functions,
not using functions appropriately to
repeat, to automate repeated tasks or
having functions that are longer
than 18 lines of code.
>> And there are some smaller issues,
like prompting the users to try again
and printing the quiz
after you replace a blank.
But overall almost all these problems
that have one commonality and
that is that they all have to do
it properly defining functions.
And because of that, we're going to
be focusing almost entirely today
how to read a problem,
break down the problem in such
a way that it makes it easy to develop
functions when the time comes forth.
>> So, one of the first places,
one of them or
one of the great way to start off
approaching this type of problem is
you've got you've got this
a much larger problem, right?
Say, the Series 2 project.
Yet it's a huge problem, that it's
create a film the blanks quits.
Now, that's going to be involving
a lot of different tasks,
a lot of different steps and really one
of the first things you want to do is,
not think about it at
that large scale problem.
You want to think about it
as these individual tasks.
>> And for that, we're not going to
kind of break down the whole problem for
you because that is-
>> It's your job.
[LAUGH]
>> It's your job [LAUGH] and
that's why you're taking this course,
but
we're going to try to use,
provide an analogous problem and
kind of show you how we need go step
by step to break down this problem.
And most importantly how
we break down this problem
can inform the way that we code
a solution to this problem.
So, today I'm going to share
this following problem with you.
It's very simple one, but
the idea is to just get you thinking
about how to extract away the big
parts of what you're being asked.
So, let's open up supply over here.
>> Gotta screen share.
>> Yeah.
I'm just pasting it here first,
one second, promise that I'll
actually doing something.
And let's share sublime.
Okay, because that shift up there.
Okay, so the problem that we're
going to be working on today is,
show user three different
people drinking Coke.
I think that's a sufficiently ambiguous
problem and some of you might be
approaching the Stage 2 project as
sufficiently ambiguous problem as well.
So for that reason,
let's just break down what it
is where Trying to talk about.
So, what does show mean here?
Well because there's sometimes like
no one we can ask to kind of clarify
the certain parts of a problem.
We sometimes have to make a reasonable
assumption about what's meant.
And try to move forward like that.
So, let's assume that in this
case show means print, it may or
may not mean it but for
our purposes in moving forward, we're
going to say that show means print.
Now, the second part of this problem is
show users three different
people drinking Coke.
[LAUGH] What does that mean?
>> [LAUGH]
>> Well I think that here we can
also make another assumption
that show means printing.
So you might want to print
three different people.
Because we're not given the people
like we're told to print out,
we can assume that we
can just make them up.
So, we can also assume
that drinking Coke could
also be like just a word, a string, you
know, some sentence that we print out.
So here, we've kind of broken
down the problem logically.
And with that we've kind of talked
out what it is you wanted to say.
And this is kind of
what we just went over.
We said that we want to
have three people,
we want a print ready to be printed.
And we want to take the first person.
Print the first person drinking Coke.
Taking the second person, print
the second person drinking Coke, and
taking the third person, and
print that person drinking Coke as well.
It seems kind of silly, but what we've
done here is just really kind of broken
down this ambiguous question,
and given ourselves in comments.
Direction to actually go forward and
code something.
>> Yeah.
And
this goes back to one of the reasons why
a lot of students don't past Stage 2.
Is not commenting at
the start of functions.
>> Right.
>> And
that's a huge reason why
the requirement exists.
We want you to start your functions with
the comment explaining what the inputs,
outputs and tasks of your function are.
>> It's a great way, actually not to do,
not only to verify that's what your
functions doing when you
are finished writing it.
But actually do it before
you even write it and
start thinking about those questions.
What are my functions input?
What are its outputs and
what tasks did it actually complete?
>> Right, I noticed here that we've
need noted what our function needs to,
well function.
We've noted the input here,
we've taken a first person and
we know the output what this
function is intended to do.
We prompt the first
person drinking Coke.
So let's go ahead and
just try and code in accordance
with what it is we commented.
I kind of like made this
in [LAUGH] beforehand.
But here we've noted that we
want to have three people,
we want to have want to print,
ready to be printed.
And I've chosen Susie who's
a fictitional character here and
me and Anthony.
And-
>> Those could also be fictional people.
>> Yes.
>> If we want them to be.
>> You never know.
[LAUGH] There might be
a second row out there.
But that being said,
we're in a good place to kind of
fill out this skeleton that we've
developed here [INAUDIBLE].
So, here we have a first
function that kind of defines
as you see drinking coke.
Here is a second function
with me drinking Coke and
here's a function with
Anthony drinking Coke.
And one thing that we kind of didn't
write was that we have to call each
one of these functions individually.
So that's-
>> I see some issues with this
code already.
And I'm assuming that maybe some
students are saying this too.
You might remember from the class
that we talk about a lot.
Big thing with functions is that
they help you avoid repetition.
But I'm seeing and we're hoping
some students see this as well,
these three functions look
really really similar.
>> Right.
>> Susie drinks Coke,
Rahul drinks Coke, Anthony drinks Coke.
What this is not doing is it's
not abstracting the problem.
It's making it very specific to
a very specific type of problem.
Does Susie drink Coke?
Does Rahul drink Coke?
Does Anthony drink Coke?
>> Right.
So, like Anthony's saying,
we've kind of repeated exactly
what it is that we're doing.
So, the thing that we went wrong
after we kind of broke down this
problem into comments is that we
didn't really group together and
identify what it is that is repeating
in the task that we created.
So we created this task that
we gotta show three people and
you gotta show them drinking,
but we didn't kind
of ask ourselves like what does it
mean for a person to drink Coke?
What does it mean for
a single instance of our problem?
And in that way we could've
grouped together the three
functionalities here, and
what we could have done is just
summarized these comments
into one comment.
And I'm going to write underneath,
and that is takes as input a string,
a person, and
prints that person drinking Coke.
>> What's really key here as I'm
looking at Rahul's code here is
he saying a person.
He's not talking about the first
person or the second person.
For hint, hint, your stage two project,
you might want to be thinking about
all right, not how do I make the easy
level work or the medium level, but
how do I make a level work?
Any level work.
>> Right.
>> That's going to be really,
really key to you
succeeding at this project.
>> Right, so
how do I pin just a single person?
Well, I do this with the belief that
once I find a way to assess for
a single person, then it's just a matter
of doing this thing x number of times.
So one way that we can kind of simplify
this problem that we have here is that
we're really just taking a person's
name and just adding drinks Coke to it.
So, in a way we just kind of written
out all of our code here first and
now we're trying to optimize for that.
So say that we have like
person drinks Coke and
instead of Susie, we just have drinks
Coke, and we pass on a person.
So in this way,
we can pass in whatever we want for
the input person, and
just have person drinks Coke.
So one way that I've optimized that.
>> You want to change that?
So that we can actually print
the person's name as well?
>> Yes.
That's what I was just about to do.
>> Cool.
>> So, so here we've kind of,
in this function that have now
written out here on line 22 here,
you see that we've take in drinks,
we take in person and drinks Coke and
we print out person plus drinks Coke.
I'm not going to build into this
because it's a pretty simple problem.
But I think that you can very obviously
see how we've just really condensed
these three functions into
one by simply thinking about
like a person versus the three
people that we have to print out.
So we can get rid of that and
we just lost like
maybe 18 lines of code which
is surprisingly the number
of lines that it takes to
not pass a submission.
So you can see that just
by this little exercise,
we've been able to eliminate a huge
portion of repeated unnecessary code.
And with that, you'll be able to kind
of kill two birds with one stone by
making a proper function and
not having it so
long that it doesn't
pass our requirements.
And you'll see that the functionality
is essentially the same,
we've just really just taken
a person and drinks Coke.
So you might be asking
yourself like what
does this have to do with
her stage two project?
And I think that we've kind of,
we've really
just own down on the ideas that
we want to kind of get you guys
to instill within yourselves after
doing this programming problem.
So after you finish a stage two problem,
we're hoping that you will now
abstract parts of the problem to make it
easier to understand how we can code it.
We want you to kind of
realize that by doing this,
you've avoided repeating
yourself in the future and
you prevented the development of really
long code from the very beginning.
You've also prevented yourselves from
repeating your code unnecessarily
by really kind of breaking down
the problem from the very beginning.
And you refine your comments
as you kind of go through
this process of eliminating extra code,
because you'll see that I took
those three original comments
that I had in passages here, and
I just condensed it into one in
the proper format that we expect.
Which I not only say what
the input to the function is,
I also say what function does.
So that in a nutshell
is kind of what it is
that you want to take from
this particular example here.
And again, in regards to what
it is this is supposed to do
in your program problem,
we want you to think about
the concept of a level
in the abstract sense.
>> Right, don't focus in so
much on how do I make my specific
construction of a level work?
How do I make my specific
construction of the easy level work?
When you have completed this project and
you've done it in a way
that uses functions well,
that uses functions that are generally
short and avoiding repetition,
what you'll find is actually that
your code will work on any level,
constructed in the way,
constructed in the expected format.
So if your code works such that
blanks are defined as underscore,
underscore, one, underscore,
underscore, and so on,
it will work on any string that
people construct In that fashion.
I could give you a random fill-in-the
blank quiz that I built and
it should work in your code
as long as it's done right.
>> Right, so that's probably a source
of a lot of problems that we have.
And remember that in the skeleton
code that you received,
that the sample that you're
given is an example a.
>> We have a question here as long
as you have your code with you.
>> Okay.
>> Asking about lines 12, 13, and 14.
So 12, 13, and 14, right, so Rahul,
can you show us your screen again and
actually show how you would call
these functions rather than.
So these functions that Rahul has at 12,
13, and
14 are obviously no longer in our code
we no longer have a Susie drinks,
Rahul drinks or an Anthony drinks.
>> Great point.
>> And so what we actually want to
do is just drinks_coffee on person1.
All right, sorry.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Drinks_coke on person1,
drinks_coke on person2,
drinks_coke on person3.
Rahul, why don't you actually run this
code so you can see what happens here?
So if we run it we can see in the output
Susie drink Coke, Rahul drinks Coke,
Anthony drinks Coke.
Again, all off of one function.
We do have to call functions for
each individual
time we want to like identify
does a single person drink Coke.
That's a result of our
construction of the function.
Our function only knows if one
single person drinks Coke.
I suppose you could construct a function
that could take in a list of people and
tell us who among them drinks Coke,
but that's a more complicated example.
Maybe that's something for
you to try at home.
>> Yeah, it might be something that you
want to implement for your CH2 projects.
But the idea here is to
kind of just simplify your thinking when
you're trying to approach this problem.
And yeah, you look at it and
said, we could probably
have something like person2 or
person3 and
then kind of adjust the inputs
here to person1, person2.
But the idea here is to simply
extract away what needs to be done so
that we're working with something
sufficient enough to pass and
pass like all the requirements
that we have.
So let's stop sharing this for a sec.
And yeah, so
those are things that we wanted
you guys to kind of come out with.
Think about a level in the abstract
sense, not three levels.
Identify what a function needs.
What needs a function?
Yeah, sorry, [LAUGH] identify what
needs a function after you've kind of
broken down the individual tasks that
you have for this problem in comments.
>> Yeah, a really great tip
that I tell a lot of students.
When you're writing a function,
really a function is like going to
perform some task for you, right?
So when you're thinking
about the big problem and
you identify the smaller tasks within
that and you figure out, okay,
I want a function that does this
particular task within the project,
think about two things before
you write any of the code.
And those two things are, what should I
expect the result of my function to be?
That's going to be your output,
what comes at the return value, and
the second piece is what
information do I need to get there?
What information am I giving,
such that I can achieve that result.
And those are your inputs or
your parameters,
what goes in the parentheses.
Those are what's going to make
things generalizable and abstracted,
so that you're able to write your
code such that it works on a abstract
input rather than a specific one.
>> Yeah, so that being said,
some last minute tips for
some things Anthony and
I noticed, and they may or
may not be things that you have to do.
If it doesn't help your thinking,
then you can ignore it.
[LAUGH] So one of the things I
do suggest you use is the exact
MADlib code that you've kind of
worked through in the work sessions.
The idea of kind of taking the MADlib's
code design is what you want to
retain from those exercises.
And that design is the replacement
of words within a log restring.
That again is the essence
of this project.
But you need to kind of find
a way to do that without,
best without like using the while loop
and extra stuff that, sorry, I shouldn't
say without using the while loop,
I don't want to get you guys confused.
And don't use the exact code that you
used before because that
can really add up in lines.
And not only that, it kind of gets
away from the problem at hand.
You want previous problems to inform
the designer of your new problems, but
generally like when you're approaching
a programming problem, you want to
break it down without any interference
from other things that you've learned.
And that's really important because the
problem that you're looking at may not
have anything to do with previous
problems you've seen before.
So make sure that you've first
written down the problem and
you have those comments where you
have exactly what you want do.
And then you can think about what it is
you did in MADlibs that might help you
in this particular situation.
>> We have a question that popped
up in the general chat from
Stefan saying the feedback he's
received on this project says that he
shouldn't be using while loops to
cycle through the four questions.
So it's hard to say without seeing
your code and I'm not fully
understanding your interpretation
of the reviewer's feedback,
but I'll try to answer
that as best as possible.
I would imagine, so
part of the specification rate is
that the user can select a level.
You might run into issues if you're
having the user select a level and
then using
a while loop to go through that because
then you might not really be selecting.
If your while loop is always
starting from the easy question, yet
I'm selecting medium,
then that's a dissociation between what
the user input is and
what your code is doing.
So again, really difficult question to
address here without seeing the code,
without seeing the reviewer feedback.
Essentially, I think it's more
this issue sounds like it might be
more specific to your code rather than
to the concept of using while loops.
There certainly is a place for
while loops in this problem.
In fact, it would be quite difficult to
do it without any to any looping there.
What I would suggest you doing,
what I suggest you to do, again,
think about the tasks.
So if there is a task which is select a
level, maybe you want to a function that
manages all the code that goes into
having the user select a level.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I'm just answering Paul's question.
I don't know if you guys had trouble
seeing the lower left corner of
the sublime text but
it was just printing out the output.
And I just posted that in the event
chat if you were wondering about that.
But exactly what Anthony's saying,
it's not about kind of,
not using a while loop here and
not using like a while loop there.
Also, it's really about kind
of breaking down a problem.
And I can't really stress this
enough because it's fundamental to
coding before.
Because I'm sure you guys either
have a firm grasp of the concepts or
can hop on 101 and then get a firm
grasp of the programming concepts.
But just problem solving in itself is
a different animal and we also want to
kind of help you guys get a mindset for
that because that's important moving on
when you see other sorts of problems
that you might be faced with.
But yeah, so we have time for
a lot more questions,
[LAUGH] any questions
that you might have.
>> Yeah, so we'll stick around for
a little while.
Q and A's open, the chat is open.
Feel free to chat at us,
ask us questions.
There'll also be a quick
survey sent out on the chat,
asking about how you felt about this new
service that we're testing out here.
We're hoping it's an improvement over
Google Hangouts which we've
been using previously.
So the survey was just
posted in the chat.
Please, please take that.
If you have time now,
feel free to use the Q&A to ask
any questions that you have.
Rodeo do you have many last tips that
you can think of while we're waiting for
questions to come in?
I actually, I guess the one
that we didn't talk about.
There's a huge thing.
In lesson 2.7 Dave talks
about this a little bit.
With the days between dates problem.
And one of the things he [INAUDIBLE]
again he breaks that down to several
tests and he talks about you know
the functions that we should use for
it and what, what goes into that.
I'll finish up my thought here and
then address the question.
One of the things he mentions
is that one of the tasks is
identifying is a year a leap year.
And he mentions that that's a very,
actually a very easy problem to solve
in the scope of a larger problem.
But he actually saves that for
the last thing that he does.
And the reason why he does that is
because evaluating whether a year is
a leap year, well that problem
in itself is a little easy.
It complicates the larger problem
that makes writing the rest
of the code more difficult.
To me that's very analogous
to the stage two project and
the idea of having the user pick a level
and one thing that I see a lot of
students do is that's the first thing
they do, is they write some code,
they write some function that allows
the user to select one of three levels.
And honestly,
that's probably one of the easier
functions to write in this assignment.
I don't recommend starting there for
the same reason that Dave does not
start with the leap year,
it complicates the rest of your code.
Because now all of a sudden you're
thinking about three different levels
and you might start falling into that
mistake that we talked about earlier
whereby you're thinking about my
specific levels rather than a level.
So I really recommend you select,
you create one example level to run your
code on and get your code to work on
that single level first in
a generalizable way, in an abstract way.
And then once you've done that then you
can start thinking, okay, so now how do
I get my user to, you to have three
different levels available to them.
You'll actually find that's very, very
easy to do if it can work on a level.
So a couple questions here in the chat.
Dan's asking how much does
the raw input part of the quiz
affect the complexity of my code?
>> I already answered that.
[LAUGH]
>> I'm just going to answer it out
loud here for
people who maybe aren't on Q and A.
So yeah, as Rahul said it's
a necessary part of the program.
It's just one line of code.
That's what's going to
allow the user to respond.
The syntax for
raw input is simply you assign raw input
to some variable in parentheses for
raw input you have a string.
That string is what
displays to the user, and
then what they type next and hit
enter gets saved to the variable, and
then you can manage
that how you see fit.
Evaluate if the answer's correct,
do whatever you need to do for
the problem.
>> Sure, let's take a look at Paul's
question, which is, which I like,
he's asking, can you show us how to
use comments to plan out your code.
I'm having trouble figuring
out what functions to make.
I'm glad that you kind of made
the analogy between comments and
functions because that's what we were
trying to hope for with this webcast.
But to use comments
to plan out the code.
The way I generally do it using
comments to clear out the code
is that I use the task that I'm
given to form the comments.
And, I hope you guys saw that when I
kind of broke down the question that I
gave myself which is show user three
different people drinking coke.
I basically, literally,
took the words from the task and
put it in comments in certain
places in order to kind
of identify directly
what it is I have to do.
Because if I take a look at the very
question that I'm being asked,
I can really, like, just on it's
face answer the question right away.
And after I've kind of written out
code and written out comments and
got a basic functionality down,
then I can kind of go back.
And at least argue that,
you know, I literally took
the problem that I was given.
And answered it.
>> A great place to start would
be the project specification.
That tells you what you're supposed
to do for this project and
that's going to lay out essentially
the rules of the game, right.
So, it's going to say it has to
display the question first and
it has to ask the user for
input and should evaluate.
Those are maybe things that you want
to think about making functions and
you might want to think okay so
which of these are tasks that belong to,
that I might have to repeat and that
should appear in a function in some way.
>> Yeah I'm really glad you mentioned
that because I think that we give a lot
of information that sometimes
might seem convoluted in
the sample code that we give you.
So what I suggest is kind of
just erasing parts of prompt
that we give you and
only leaving like little action items.
>> Like literally break it down into
steps, step one, step two, step three.
>> Yeah.
>> And then go forth.
>> And they're literally in comments
already so, right then there.
[LAUGH] You already have like your task.
>> Comments are great way to store those
like, some people call it pseudocode.
Essentially it's like a step by
step process in algorithm towards
solving a problem but not written
in a computer programming language.
Jennifer also has a question.
So as far as asking the user
to choose a level in our quiz,
is it appropriate to use if
else statements for level?
Yes, in fact that's probably
one of the best ways to do it.
It kind of goes on programming style.
But essentially I guess two
ways you could do this.
Is one you could do it
at the global level.
Meaning not inside of any function.
And just that code is run immediately
upon when you run the file, or
you could do it in a function itself.
I personally am a proponent of thinking
that code shouldn't be written up at
the global level, but
that's going to be up to you and
your personal preference and
style to decide that.
But really.
I mean you can think about it like this,
right?
So you have some prompt saying please
select a level, you're going to get
that user's response, and then you
want to find out if they said easy,
if they said medium, if they said hard,
or if they said something else.
If you start to think or say problems
like that out loud to yourself, they
kind of give you hints about what coding
techniques you might find helpful here.
>> Yeah I mean are-
>> Use these keywords and
it's like if is a keyword in
Python because it means something.
It's not like it's just some weird word.
It's always like if this condition then
do something else, that's English.
>> So I think that we're.
Well, unless anyone has
any more questions,
we can kind of wrap this up right now.
But, it seems like you guys have
been asking some great questions and
from the questions that you've
been asking it seems that you have
hopefully gained a better mindset of
how to tackle not only this problem but
other problems that you might face,
not only in this area but,
in the future of your
programming career.
If that's the last question I think
that we can kind of end this webcast.
>> Yeah sounds good to me.
>> Awesome.
>> Also thanks for coming in today.
Fill out the survey.
Good luck with stage two.
We're here to help you
if you need more help.
>> Eat your vegetables.
>> {LAUGH] Yeah, eat your vegetables.
>> See you guys.
>> All right, see you.